let's see why don't we go next we are
taking calls six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty let's try the
8:05 area code isn't 8:05 is that
Pensacola Florida area uh no that's
California oh okay maybe eight five zero
is the Pensacola Florida area all right
go ahead who's this um hello my name is
Christian great Christian from
California what's on your mind today um
I was wondering do you believe that
someone can have a negative or critical
take away of your coverage of the illah
no more controversy without accusing you
of accusing Representative Omar of
anti-semitism oh sure yeah anybody I
mean listen look at the email I get
every day people can have negative
takeaways from every single segment
every time all right cool cuz it just
seems like you somewhat contradicted
that sentiment in your recent video
about the tattling of the Sam cedar
collar you know that color who
misrepresented your position on health
care right it seems it seems as this in
that video you sort of strawman his
position on Alana Omar he merely said
that your take was a bad take but then
you went on like a two minute rant about
how people constantly accuse you of
accusing her of anti-semite so if you go
back to the clip I certainly was not
accusing that caller of making the
allegation since he mentioned it in the
spur of the moment I'm just you know
doing a show where I'm reacting to what
I hear that caller certainly did not
accuse me of that being my position but
the caller then did misrepresent my
position on health care and to give the
example if the caller had even called
Sam cedar and said hey David Pakman says
he's open to solutions that get coverage
to everyone that are not necessarily
medicare-for-all what do you think about
that that's great because it's actually
an accurate representation of what I
said
unfortunately he called and said
something like I'm going from memory
here something like David Pakman is you
know moving away from medicare-for-all
and is in favor of the public option
it's like no dude I didn't say that
right right I'm not
defending his position on that I did
seem I just wanted to clarify your
position on the ill on Omar controversy
and how people can maybe have negative
takeaways without necessarily
misrepresenting your position and he
won't even bear any of my positions and
have a negative take away without
misrepresenting it and that is what I
call good-faith disagreement but I'm
glad that we've now clarified my
position on the caller's position on my
position and that now your position will
be better informed right right right
all right Christian great to hear from
you appreciate the phone call thank you
okay